hey everybody good morning and happy new
year from the great and free state of
florida
today is january 3rd 2022
and we wanted to restart the show today
that was the original plan when i fled
la with my team about two and a half
weeks ago that we were going to get into
our house the new house a few days ago
we were going to put together a
makeshift studio while we built out the
incredible new studio that we're working
on and we have awesome plans on and
everything else but unfortunately things
have been a little slow here in florida
obviously everyone and their brother got
covered in the last two weeks then
between christmas and years just been a
little slow to close on the house so i'm
still staying at friends on the water
over here as you can see clyde's clyde's
digging it uh but i wanted to check in
with you guys just to let you know i
didn't disappear
uh i didn't get eaten by an alligator
yeah what do you got for us
um everything has been absolutely
amazing here uh
well except for the fact that aoc showed
up in miami as i'm sure betty if you saw
and she's dancing and hanging out in
huge crowds with no mask and no social
distancing what an entitled socialist
gross lockdown happy mandate who she is
but in any event everything else here
has been wonderful there are so many
people here that are so happy that are
so ready to save america people are
moving here from all over the place they
know what they're fleeing the people
that have lived here and done it right
are happy i've seen them there already
uh it's just been it's just been great
like really really great so anyway i do
want to get back into the studio as
quickly as possible uh i believe it will
happen
next monday next monday i think we can
get into the house this weekend we're
gonna throw together some very
rudimentary studio situation and we'll
start shooting there uh for a little bit
as we build out the uh the main studio
i'm just super psyched i feel like this
is gonna be a great year i genuinely do
i'm not just saying it like to me it
feels like there's a chance now like so
many people
are seeing through the [ __ ] people
are realizing how many people in media
and in politics and the scientists all
these people that have just lied and
lied and lied and enough people have had
enough and and the fight is on and uh
and i'm here in florida where i'm gonna
fight to keep florida florida i think
this is sort of ground zero of america's
ability to have a comeback and maybe
that's for the whole uh free world to
have a comeback that it all kind of
starts here clyde's a little exhausted
hearing me talk about this type of stuff
all the time but i'm psyched i
appreciate your patience everybody i
promise you uh that we'll be back
shooting normally uh soon enough if i
can get in to the house today or
tomorrow we can hopefully start shooting
some stuff
even by thursday or friday i just don't
want to over promise at the moment so it
looks like monday stretching it out
stretching it out
you like that air huh glad you got
anything to tell the good people
anything anything okay
uh anyway guys uh
happy new year
hope you all enjoyed christmas time with
some family
i hope you're just feeling good about
things because uh
something's turned something's turning
and maybe i've just hopped up on florida
freedom but i don't think so i think
there's something bigger going on here
so all right we're back in studio soon
and you want to keep playing along i've
been uh you know posting other videos
and some more personal stuff over at the
locals community reubenreport.locals.com
uh all right that's it ciao
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell